I can emergency surgery to perform in  Baltimore I'll fly wherever I happen  tonight to get there tomorrow morning  can you help me sir  I think we may have the same problem I  have an idea so what's the rush I'm  getting married tomorrow  Oh congratulations no no it's we're not  we just met  what Vicki Idaho medical conference  we're ending it I would explain the  questions  [Music]  anyone  hello delicately you really hurt your  leg the phone smashed my phone has no  signal and we're pretty high up in the  mountain if we stay here we'll say if we  leave there to rescue they're less  likely to find us look I want to die up  here because you're too scared to take a  risk someone's career for Pilate in  France lately  nobody knows where we are we're all we  got me and you if you go three weeks  without food three days without water  and three hours without shelter  we might die together I don't even know  you  [Music]  the diet  Oh today  all right  [Music]  you